water is one of the most essential
ingredients for life to exist on Earth
but did you know that it might be older
than our own planet and the Sun and even
though solar system
theorized that during a phase called the
late heavy bombardment millions of time
in meteoroids which are asteroids and
comets hit the earth transferring water
from outer space onto the surface of the
Earth and that is how oceans were formed
over a long long period of time now this
means that this essential liquid that we
drink and that makes up our oceans might
be millions of years older than the
solar system
so the next time we take a sip of water
remember that it might have originated
millions and millions of years ago
some corner of the universe
other Celestial body
which consists of water I'll give you a
hint it is in our solar system itself
comment down below and subscribe to
normal price